Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P People are calling
in because of the story I told on the bonus
show about my flight back from San Francisco
and people are criticizing me
even though I was the victim
of pricks on my flight. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: David, it's Alan from Jersey.
I was listening to the bonus show yesterday and
you were telling another story of your airline
travel. And all these airline travel
stories you tell are exactly the same.
Speaker 1: I've told like two stories, and.
Speaker 3: You're the only one that knows the
procedure to get to your seat. You're the only
one that knows the right time to put the window
shade up, the right time to put the window
shade down, the proper procedure to get your
bag in the overhead bin. You're the only one who
knows how to do the roller bag and the personal
item. Everybody else is doing it wrong. David,
you're the only one. Or perhaps David In these
situations. In these situations, you should step
back and say, Am I the only one that knows how to
put the badge in the overhead bin? Am I the only
one? Or perhaps everybody else is doing it the
right way and you're doing it the wrong way?
Speaker 1: David I'm the problem, clearly.
Speaker 3: Think about this, David, because
it can't be that everybody else is always
wrong and doing it the wrong way. All right.
Speaker 1: Listen, dude, I told one story in
2021 on a Lufthansa flight from Frankfurt to JFK,
in which I explained that there was a particular
guy. Okay, this was a 747 out of 400 people.
There was one guy who yelled at me because I used
an overhead bin. All the other 399 people on the
flight did the right thing. It's not everybody's
doing it wrong and I'm doing it right. I then have
had ten flights since then where nobody's done
anything wrong. And last week on my flight back
from San Francisco, one guy jumped ahead of me,
pushed his way past me to cram his bag into the
obvious spot where I was about to lift my bag.
The 180 people on that flight, 179 of them,
including my daughter, all behaved perfectly.
It's not everybody's doing everything
wrong. Get out of here. Give me a break,
dude. Okay. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. The Supreme Court is putting some First
Amendment limits on laws that ban online threats.
Why? What are those limits? We're going to discuss
it. There is a Delaware City that is going to
give corporations the right to vote in elections.
What? Yes. And lastly, a Republican senator is
challenging a union leader to a mixed martial
arts fight. At least it's for charity. All of
it we are going to talk about on the bonus show.
Speaker 4: A David Pac-Man
membership because six bucks a month.
Speaker 1: True. But with a discount code, it's
only two. You can use the discount code. Indicted
again. And we will have such a great bonus show
for you today. We will see you then. Otherwise,
I will be back here tomorrow. If I have anything.
Unidentified: To say about.